sam i am goddamn upset jeez i hate when
you're angry i just watched harry potter
you know what there wasn't any blood in
that movie magic is very dangerous and
very deadly and harry potter really kind
of [ __ ] footed around all that okay
yeah i i buy that i mean these spells
are like kind of high level magic even
that kid who got knocked out cold hit
his head on the ground nothing this
should be more violent than a gun this
can blow people up can turn them into
balloons can transform them into animals
against their will people are supposed
to be dying left and right i'm just
feeling really upset about all this i
can cheer you up what if
i told everyone in the studio
to fix the movie for you
you really do that for me i will
personally
make sure
that they do those shots for you
is it harry potter time you're a wizard
samuel so are you we're both wizards
look at that hey so i got some wizard
clips for you guys to check out
you're a wizard harry harry potter my
name is mary with mary potter and i have
a magic wand
here's the thing i didn't get about
harry potter though which was like all
right we got a magic school it's cute
magic hijinks but then like literally
terrorists attack it and like kill
people and like they refuse to like
close the school it's it's very dark the
way they describe things in these books
and so i'm surprised they didn't put any
of that violence in the actual fights i
mean people get hit in the face and get
knocked out and stuff but there's no
blood or guts or anything the quidditch
games like can be lethal like kids are
almost dying
but look at that he's dead dude even in
the book
quidditch is described as like a deadly
sport
so there's a great little moment here
with this photographer whoa
that's perfect you just will freeze him
so he doesn't duck and he'll just you'll
just you'll just clip them like
yeah just in some classic like are you
getting somebody to spell but like my
guts yeah we could get creative with it
it doesn't just need to be like spell
guts like spell like an actual spell
where like you grow a boot out of your
side but it's like bullying or something
like that because they have some pretty
goofy spells in harry potter i feel like
we could really milk that
one's at the reddit
[Music]
so i have a wacky idea that matt and i
created together draco malfoy basically
turns hairy he like cripples him up into
a little basketball shape and he like
starts dribbling him like under the legs
and stuff and he's like going towards
the end of the table and like a trap
door opens up and a basketball hoop
comes out and then he just like leaps
and dunks him in the basketball hoop and
then all the little kids with their foam
fingers are like
it's going to require a full 3d
reconstruction of that area so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to roughly
model that scene throat slap some
textures on it and then there's a lot of
random children in this scene and i want
to be able to like create some new shots
so i gotta fully populate it so what
i've been doing is i'm searching like
harry potter robe costume on google
images and i find just like the amazon
listing images for these robe costumes
and i'm taking that and then i'm feeding
it into pie fudd which is an open source
2d image to 3d model converter you feed
it this image and it spits out a very
janky but usable 3d model and i slapped
our 3d scans of our heads onto the
students we got dean we got clint we got
me we got ren we got nick in there uh
making up the student body of hogwarts
and if it's just like a crowd full of
little youngins you won't be able to
notice yeah so i'm doing spike wall in
lego harry potter so the kid it's a
little kid and he's trying to do his
best to do his best spell on harry
and he turns harry into lego harry
potter
and he's like oh crap i'm a lego and his
head just
pops off and like lego blood starts like
shooting out so that's the first one and
then the second one is from the same
scene that peter's doing one of the
teachers gets freaking wrecked by snape
and he goes flying and i want to get him
up against like a spike wall so he
basically goes flying into this
giant spike wall if y'all don't think
there's enough violence what i'm going
to be doing is i'm doing the quidditch
match and that's going to be a violent
mess kids are going to be brutally
murdered i'm so excited to see
everybody's so yeah
it's always the best part
but hagrid this is platform nine and
three quarters there's no such thing
is there
hey ren
oh my god are you okay
why would you do that dude i'm on a
mission
trying to find platform 10 and
two-thirds i heard it's a magical place
where your renders are instantaneous did
sam tell you about this yeah sam told me
all about it yeah it's one of these
walls it's been a while well while i go
look for that i figured i'd kill two
birds with one stone and tell you all
about squarespace which is today's
sponsor what are you doing trying to
find platform ten to two-thirds where my
renders are instantaneous speaking of
which squarespace has the number one
award-winning customer service
oh it wasn't that wall
we'll find it
i'm gonna try this wait wait wait wait
wait
we already tried that wren
[Music]
yeah you're right don't want to try this
one however squarespace does have a huge
variety of templates that make
customizing your website super easy
unlike finding this dang platform
maybe it's been covered by the painting
oh that's a perfect cover-up
okay dude it's definitely this wall dude
i have a good feeling about this
okay before i go through the portal
though squarespace allows multiple
contributors so that you can have your
whole team accessing your website and
contributing to it with different levels
of permissions it's pretty great because
teamwork makes the dream work you got
this ren
oh that wasn't the portal
but hey at least on squarespace you can
be sure that you own
all of the content that you post
okay i think i know where it is finally
but what's cool is that squarespace has
traffic overview giving you insights on
the top traffic sources for your website
all right i think this is it
[Music]
is that it no no that wasn't it that's
not it sorry nico you okay
wasn't that one
platform ten and two thirds yeah
it's just right there you just have to
go through that wall all right i think i
can do that so guys all you gotta do is
go to squarespace.com quarter crew and
you will get 10 off your first domain or
website it's pretty incredible
i can feel its presence it's right here
i'm gonna jump that's it that's it i can
feel it okay i can feel it like i didn't
feel any of the other walls you ready
yeah
what the frick
did you see that
huh
so for one of my scenes here i'm doing
quidditch now quidditch should be a
deadly sport more kids should be dying
from a sport where you literally fly on
a broomstick and beat people with bats
and stuff i'm doing this scene where
harry and malfoy are being chased by
this rogue bludger in the movie colin
creevy he's taking a picture as harry is
flying past him this boy ducks and
narrowly escapes death uh i wanted to
change that what happens if our sweet
little collin does not duck how do you
decapitate a child so i had to first of
all make a clean plate and then i used
the puppet tool just to give him a
little bit of motion back and then i
needed a bunch of blood you see all
these blood hits here and one sneaky
little trick
i used to make the brains work
basically i just use cc shatter just on
the 2d image of his head so you add
motion blur to that and it just looks
like little
brain splatters
so you can see that i've also tracked
his head onto the bludger to do this i
had to create a pretty gnarly looking
head this is our
horrifying looking boy it does kind of
look like peter yeah yeah it kind of
looks like me as a little baby
so the wind would be affecting his hair
and his little flappy bits that are just
dangling in order to stimulate that
effect i applied a puppet tool and a
bunch of points that are on the outside
and on the inside i applied a wiggle
expression too just kind of sells that
sort of momentum that's death footage
that's death quidditch for you
for this
it's harry potter too you're draco
malfoy you're facing off against harry
potter and this little [ __ ] has been
giving you trouble since day one oh
harry potter is so special oh it's like
i'm a freaking malfoy you know i got
lineage son over the summer you've been
playing a lot of basketball and so you
got this spell that's going to make a
basketball hoop emerge from the dueling
table then you're going to shoot harry
with a spell that turns him into a
basketball you're going to go you're
going to dribble harry down the court
then you're going to run up
and then like don't carry right in the
hoop it's taking me back to my
basketball days when i was better than
everyone when i dunked on all those
little vietnamese children
let's get you uh calibrated let's get
you in your heterosexual pose
moving around
shake it out
all right draco are you ready oh i'm
ready
oh you ready
three
two
one action
[Music]
dude i
don't know what that mocap data is going
to look like it janked out pretty hard
[Laughter]
all right i'm recording
let's go
whoa recording three two one action
[Music]
[Music]
that's the one that's the one
it's perfect it's perfect it's r rated i
was worried this wasn't going to be
rated enough and this pushes it over the
edge
oh ren thank you this is perfect
good enough
rated r harry potter what the heck am i
gonna do i have this idea that's not
quite rated r but i'm gonna try and make
it as rated r as possible i want to turn
harry potter into lego harry potter
which to me is terrifying to be turned
into a piece of plastic you don't have
elbows anymore you don't have knees
anymore you only got one hairstyle his
head just like shoots off and then
little blood pieces just start like
spurting out of his neck hole and then
he just face plants onto the ground and
he just starts shooting blood everywhere
griffin actually whipped together some
super legit harry potter heads for me
and they're all different states of what
he's feeling in the moment but yeah i
just hand animated a little lego guy in
cinema 4d now from here i have to light
it to make it look like the scene from
the movie look at the original scene and
really study it and ask yourself where's
the lighting coming from and if you look
closely you can see that he's being
under lit he's standing on this grating
and they're shooting a large soft light
up from underneath the floor so i know
i'm gonna do exactly that in 3d i have
this big old area light down here
blasting light up from underneath the
ground but if you look at the footage
too you can also see that he's kind of
lit from the top as well adding these
lights these hair lights really add to
your render and they make it look really
nice so i have these two lights on the
left and right so now i've successfully
lit my lego character to look
like the actual harry potter in the
actual scene now all i have to do is
animate it i actually filmed myself
doing this movement this is something i
learned from alex on our animators react
show and this is something that he does
across his entire career as he films
himself and then he animates based off
of that reference so i basically filmed
myself as lego harry potter as reference
and then from there it's just keyframe
animation hand animation frame by frame
animation to get this natural feeling
look out of this i used dynamics to pop
the head off i gave it some upwards
force now from here the last thing i
need to do is really make this bloody so
i wanted to keep everything based off of
legos this tiny little red translucent
puck that is actually a lego piece and
i'm gonna have these be shot out of an
emitter that's connected to harry's
torso and it's just spraying out all
over the ground give him a little bit of
blur a little bit of noise to composite
him a little bit better into the scene
i'm just excited for peter's shot that's
all i mix
peter shot
petrificus
[Music]
so lauren nico and clint actually just
reviewed this shot on stuntman react
because it's a pretty crazy stunt like
this person literally falls over just
like
so you have that to look forward to in a
future stunt and react episode with
lauren who is in the mandalorian quite a
bit the idea here is that neville is
frozen and when he falls down he
shatters so the way dynamics work in
cinema 4d is basically you hit play and
it plays out the dynamics but there's a
bit of like noise in the system
intentionally so so every time i
simulate this it's a little different so
basically all i'm doing here is just
simulating over and over and over trying
to get different sort of results
primarily i'm just trying to get like a
cool looking final image like one where
like the skull is looking right at the
camera right
that's not bad the little foot bouncing
in there at least the skull is facing
the camera and the foot did a little
funny like
but it's not ideal there's a whole bunch
of like neville's skin blocking his
empty skull so i'm gonna recast that so
clear cash
bake again
if you wanna bake a party cake yeah have
you seen that dean
you have no idea what i'm talking about
bake a pretty cake little john
[Music]
break it down
break it down [ __ ] let me see you back
it up
so yeah that's what baking in cinema 4d
is like
oh
the foot it's always the it loves the
foot it just has a foot thing
that's pretty sweet but there's a lot
left to finish this shot so i'm gonna
try to see if i can project the actual
texture from him in the movie onto the
geometry and then i'm gonna try to
replicate the lighting of the scene that
we're in and then i'm gonna render it
i'm so excited to see harry potter rated
art sam's been working really hard all
week this isn't harry po this isn't the
video but i always make sure that they
put 100 into everything making a
franchise rated r is a really big task
i'm really hopeful that this is going to
be
special
i know that peter's been up late on
these shots for the past few nights it's
been taxing me knowing that he's
working so hard so
you know i just hope it comes out well
so we got this freaking dunk sequence so
i kind of got swept up in the idea of
draco dunking harry because i thought
that was really funny and i forgot that
it was supposed to be r-rated but being
turned into a basketball is inherently a
little r-rated because if you're getting
compressed into a little ball you're
going to have bones snapping you're
going to have internal bleeding there's
going to be like blood leaking through
your clothes and stuff it's not going to
be a pleasant experience and so i kind
of just leaned into that but before we
get there we had to get the draco and
harry 3d models and for those i was very
lazy i just googled draco malfoy 3d
model i downloaded the first thing that
came up same thing with harry but
for one shot we have a close-up of
draco's face and this is like a video
game 3d model which just looks super
janky and so what i ended up doing was i
took a still of draco's face from the
movie and i projected it onto his 3d
model
at the correct perspective of the shot
from the movie so when you see it in
motion it looks
still kind of janky but it works as a
close-up so we got draco all set up and
ready to go then what i did was i took
ren's motion capture data i slapped that
on there cleaned it up a bit and it was
good to go so we have our nice motion
capture going on but we can't really
motion capture a basketball so i had to
animate that by hand which was actually
surprisingly
the most challenging part of this
process because ren was doing all these
fancy dribbling moves i didn't know
where the hell the basketball was
supposed to be so i actually had to have
friends sit down with me and be like
okay here i was putting it in between my
legs and here i was passing it between
my back and that took a good chunk of
time to animate that ball bouncing by
hand so i'm pretty happy with how this
scene turned out i think it's pretty
funny but the thing that's going to take
it to the next level is
the sound we got some guttural screams
in there this might not be r-rated
enough but with the right screams we can
take it over the edge so let's go do
that three
two
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that's fun that's great
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's so intense
i don't know i've been really stressing
about this because like i know these
guys have been working really hard but i
really haven't been checking in on them
so honestly i have no idea what we're in
store for this could go in either
direction and if if nico doesn't like
this i'm gonna be in big trouble is
harry potter done harry potter's done i
think we're ready right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's no reason why he wouldn't get
what he wants today so
we're gonna play this video for nico
and he's going to freaking like it i'm
excited
oh you got your wand ready are you ready
you go i really i really hope you like
what i did for you yeah i hope you guys
don't disappoint me
may i present harry potter raided on
oh
wow
[Music]
i'll fight you petrificus
you're a little scary sometimes that
looks really good
yeah it looks so good
stunning is one of the most useful
spells in your arsenal it's it's sort of
a wizard's bread and butter really so um
come on then nigel
give it your best shot
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dunk on him heady shakiliosis
[Music]
scoliosis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
diagonally
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i think you guys
especially you sam
did a great job
making harry potter
way more what i wanted to see when i
think of magic and wizards fighting like
i want to see people get their bones
broken as they get turned into a
basketball and slam dunk i want to see
children shatter into pottery while
their skeleton remains intact and all
the blood disappears
you know i wasn't expecting uh memes to
make their way into this and that was
that was delightful um the amount of cg
was really cool this is my harry potter
[Applause]
[Music]
this is all super cool you guys really
knocked it out of the uh cafeteria hall
stained glass window no you guys did a
great job and if you guys enjoyed
watching this we have a couple other
rated r things that we've done on this
channel we've done marvel we've done
star wars and we got all those in a
playlist
so what would you like to see us make
rated r next please leave a comment
below because we're out of ideas
i'm just kidding
they said spykins let us know if you
want that
carmen judy close your eyes we don't
want you to see this okay